now first Jennifer I'm just curious how
many phone calls have you gotten from
music labels since Graham Norton
revealed Japan no I don't know why wait
just wait yeah it must have been was a
weekend actually from friends no yeah
it's overwhelming
around like people don't know what to
say in the face of that exactly now
watching this movie I couldn't help but
feel a connection with Rosa younger
actress in the big sci-fi movie you
office you got your start in the
labyrinth young actress yeah but like
that was really like a big break for you
just like with Rosa do you feel like you
want to give her advice like meant to
her a little bit as a younger actress no
I don't know I feel like that would be
presumptuous I don't like to - how to
advise anyone she seems to be doing just
fine for herself
yeah when it comes to her character I
mean I would say she's ambiguous I guess
is a good word to describe like you're
not exactly sure what she's up to when
you first meet her in those first few
scenes like was that part of the appeal
of the character that she's is
mysterious in a way yeah I think it's
like a contentious relationship between
her and Aleta
she's definitely positioned as an
adversary and yeah she's miserable my
character is miserable at the beginning
she just want to get out of there but I
think in a kind of delicious way she's
she's you know she's sort of a slightly
kind of fun adversary I think she was to
me anyway and then and then you come to
understand why she's behaving like that
and so I liked her as a character and I
thought the big project character was
just the costumes I mean the costumes
were amazing it really how much does
that play into you establishing who the
character is I think it came out of it
was very much and keeping the design of
the costumes I think really reflected
everything about her I think they were
really good cuz they captured what she
was about you know which was she didn't
want to she didn't see herself reflected
in this world so she didn't want to in
any way be part of it she didn't want to
touch anything so she's got these gloves
she wants to be above it so she just
everything about her is saying I don't
belong here and I think that the
Wardrobe really captured that and this
is based on a Japanese series so
obviously there's a fan base built into
that you're joining a Top Gun at two
which has a little bit of a fan base as
well really beloved series so with these
kind of projects is there more pressure
there when there is an established
audience for it
I don't know I I yes and no so first of
all I feel like every every day I go to
work I feel like it's an opportunity no
matter what the project is and I feel
holdin to it and I feel like I want to
make the most of every opportunity that
I have
so I always feel that you know but yes
certainly on top of that there's you
know you don't want to let those people
down and you want to understand what it
is what their expectations are and in
whatever way I can you know meet those
expectations or at least respect and
honor and have an understanding of what
those expectations are you know do you
ride in the jet and talkin to just tell
me that I can't tell you okay fine
alright on motorcycle okay that's good
you